hey I was in one of those commercials
really that was like the first
commercial I ever booked I was in a
divide commercial that played at the
movie theater so so if I went to go
watch movies back then I would see
myself in and I'm like on a computer I'm
just like
[Music]
okay did you guys know what that Target
has dropped 15 in stonks since
so Target stocks have taken a beating
okay since all this Pride stuff right so
they were they were having like because
they got the tuck your penis thongs yes
they do they do have tuck your penis
thongs oh is that what they look like
they look like this yeah tomboy tomboy X
talking hiding bikini underwear for
compression and they'll have them in the
kids session and that's why parents are
pissed yeah this is the next one don't
like Market the sexualization to my kids
it's the marketing game for adults do
your thing but like now if my kid who's
barely still picking his nose or her
nose is walking around they're like what
do you mean tuck my penis away that's
like the opposite of sexual though isn't
it like don't look at it like you're
trying to hide it well it's it's women's
clothes for biological dudes that are I
want to tuck it away it's very
complicated I think that's the main
thing that parents are like it's a very
complicated thing someone that's eight
and is what I think parents would matter
what if they're not yeah what if they're
nice
what if it's just a good pair of
underwear did you guys hear about the
whole um the reason why a lot of these
companies are doing it this way or doing
this is because
um
there's some kind of like uh diversity
index thing that a lot of companies have
to scale high on it's called CSG or some
[__] yeah yeah and then if they don't
hit that Mark ESG yeah ESG ESG like and
it's it's a it's a bad evaluation for
the company which will drop its stocks
all this stuff so they're like more
willing to do this and be controversial
and maybe even take a a slight hit
because in the long run what they're
more concerned about is the owners of
the stocks like a shareholder so it's
part of like the ultimate Finance game
it's like yeah because then a lot of
people were saying like why would Bud
Light and all these companies do this
and alienate their you know consumers
like and why would they do this if it's
hurting their own company and other
companies see that it's doing it but
they keep doing it right yeah and then
they're like and then this guy came out
and goes well it's because they don't
care about the consumer because you're
gonna forget about it and keep buying
anyway like this this is the real reason
why and then there's like all these
governing groups and there's like a
criteria that you have to check off and
it's like it's a lot of but Bud Light is
like was nuts because Bud Lights like
their target audience is just like
truckers and [__] that's like having
like [__] Peterbilt or John Deere
come out and be like we got we got a
[__] rainbow colored uh you know
steerman today or whatever yeah people
just but their their execution was
pretty heavy-handed it was different
yeah but like but generally like that
whole movement or whatever they're
trying to do is like it's the diversity
thing all that stuff I guess it's like
for a completely different agenda not
trying to sell products it's required of
them to do that more business incentives
yeah I went to a pride event last night
and Bud Light had a gay Bud Light stance
and they had some like gay Bud Lights
like and it was all color like in
rainbow balloons and everything itself
just gay now I think so yeah but it is a
pretty game he tries like my dick
honestly I tried it
I was like nobody hey man come on chill
dude what the hell man what I thought so
didn't they retract and then they got
they were like too much in the middle so
like they went they're like hey are bad
and then yeah [__] you dude yeah and
they try to backtrack they got both
sides and like hey truckers we miss you
and like [__] you yeah and so now
they're going back to the gay community
to can you guys take us back well this
is same as it ever was kind because like
I'm sure they already had like stuff
going going back for a long time make
pictures of them doing gay pride parades
and stuff I've seen those yeah but it's
just this one moment like this Dylan
mavaney can thing it went like kind of I
think it's the trans thing like there
was never a problem with companies you
know supporting gay things it's like now
that it's trans it was way more divisive
hmm so my question is why do these like
conservative people why do they care so
much if there is like a rainbow can or
something like or just like something
that might confirm the existence of gay
people like why does that make them so
upset like I don't understand like where
those emotions come from personally
I've been trying to live action role
play that myself and I have not gotten
there I can't find the outrage I I
honestly I can't think it like the
people writing articles and stuff like
this isn't the first time that uh Beer
Company sponsored gay events and gay no
yeah it's it's always been a thing but
maybe now they're starting to see like a
div like not a division but just like
it's not so much clear-cut as like gay
and lesbian transgender all of that is
not grouped up into one it might be more
like yeah it to me it seems like they
have an issue with like uh I guess
transgenderism or what's going on right
now with the whole political climate
with
um not being able to choose between
who's a man who's a woman all that like
like the that's the debate right now
that's the fight right to me I feel like
it's almost even even bigger than that I
think it's gender politics I think it's
a right left issue and whatever is the
new topic both sides fight to the death
so I think I think it even started with
like George Floyd stuff right like cops
is there police brutality once yes once
no fight to the death right and then
okay what's the next thing the next
thing is now like rainbow stuff what's
your stance [__] you like I don't I
don't think there's a logical argument I
just think there's everyone's dying on
their heads yeah the last three to four
years has been so much tension with
everything with everything [__] water
[__] whatever every any any topic I know
let's talk about water I don't know but
it just feels like that it feels like
anything nobody cares about actually
there is there's uh there's like the
[__] drought people and then there's
the people that are like no it's a
conspiracy they keep dumping water
and it's always or like borders one is
like let them all in like keep all of
them out and like every every single
thing it's like hard 180 degree stances
yeah it's wing on wing with no
compromise or any type of like
conversation yeah that's what it feels
like so I feel like it's actually I
don't even think any of these topics
really matter to them and I think it
matches the People Like Us like oh we
want this or we don't want this but I
think the people that are at the
Forefront of it they're just they're
divisive as [__] yeah it's just it's
just being used as a puppet or a
scapegoat to have a bigger argument
that's what I feel like but like people
they Bud Light stands at least they just
didn't want a part of that conversation
I think it was fair to assume they just
didn't want to have to say whether they
were for it or not but now they do
because now it's inside their brand so
then they're forced to either be upset
about it or not be but they just didn't
want either so they just wanted to drink
beer but by drinkers like let's say you
have a fridge stock full of the old can
yeah they see this can yeah do they take
all their old cats and dump that out too
the actual can doesn't exist
it was just for the ad yeah it wasn't
actually a thing it literally it was a
Warner yeah it was it was it was never a
real thing in stores it was just for the
Dylan Mulvaney like spot people all
reacted but they overreacted like crazy
they were like I'm not gonna stock that
can in my store but it's like it's not a
real can well sometimes too there is a
thing you know you're I think you're
right you say there's always people on
the wings right nobody wants to have a
conversation in the middle but then
sometimes I'm like do I really want to
have this conversation
they didn't want to talk like we'll be
here we'll like have some guests on JK
and I hear them say something that I'm
like I personally disagree with this but
I do I really want to spend the rest of
the day like at my like taking minor
shots exactly because it doesn't matter
no do not correct what an assault rifle
is just leave it alone exactly exactly
so I have a conspiracy as to why people
are so mad about the whole trans thing
okay I think it's almost just as we're
moving into the future we're seeing a
lot less like masculinity in general
because you know dudes are just staying
inside playing video games they're in
school you know just on computers all
the time like probably watching a lot of
porn and stuff like men just like aren't
masking anymore porn is better than has
been ever has been yeah that's the
problem that's the problem though that's
kind of the problem it is yeah but I
think men in general are just becoming
like way less masculine and then people
like maybe they'll understand why so
they're trying to blame it on the trans
movement like they're trying to like
trying to shift the blame
um with the ACT instead of to avoid
accountability yeah yeah or trying to
focus on like the shitty diets that
people eat that are causing them to be
less masculine and stuff yeah that's why
I want carnivore brother I also think
like to Bart's point of why it's so
uh polar now to where the the left and
the right are at like it's almost like a
cultural War it's not like we're both
Americans and we have different
ideologies and let's just kind of hash
this out
yeah because there's not like there's
not one thing you guys agree on no
they're not even one you know it's like
literally opposite of every single thing
because I think this is what what used
to be like when when we were kids I
thought that the left was the working
class representation and then the right
was more like small business big
business it was more conservative and
old school right but the tying common
cultural thing to me was Christianity
today's video is brought to you by Warby
Parker you know I like seeing sunglasses
like this sometimes on the interwebs
but one of the biggest problems is I
never buy sunglasses online because I
never know if it's gonna fit or not
um but what's awesome about Warby Parker
is you can try these on at home before
you even buy it and not even one at a
time too because that would be a pain in
the ass would you put one on oh man it's
too small or it's too big doesn't fit my
face you can get five of them so you get
your top five choices which is even
better than three and you try it at home
you're like okay you know what I'm gonna
keep this one or this one or this one
and send it back yeah you can just go
ahead and browse their website they got
so many different kinds of glasses the
sunglasses to whatever you want to get
right and then you're like I like this I
want to try that and then you could be
at home putting it on putting some
clothes on does it fit with this outfit
does it fit with my facial frames and
then you go okay I'm gonna keep these
five so Warby Parker offers you
everything that you need for happier
eyes eyeglasses sunglasses even contact
lenses and eye exams and you can shop
with them online or in stores I been
seeing them around and glasses start at
95 bucks including the prescription
lenses try Warby Parker's free try on
home program order five pairs of glasses
to try at home for free there's no
obligation to buy ships free and
includes a prepaid shipping label try
five pairs of glasses at home for free
at warbyparker.com off the Record and we
were an actual like pretty Christian
Nation but now the left has way more
atheists they're way more um they're
culturally way more different it's like
West Coast I would say it's even West
Coast snobbery or like Coastal major
cities and it's all the people that
didn't belong in Christian conservative
Lifestyles that want to run away from it
and then so since they were outcasted
from them but also they abandoned the
working class so
um during the Clinton Administration and
on I think like they started really
focusing on big business getting
campaign funding they wanted to play the
game that the Republicans were paying
playing getting a bunch of money from um
corporate donors and stuff
so then what ended up happening is like
now they're sponsored by big Tech you
know they're sponsored by like different
special interests and they're they're
doing the same thing that they resented
the conservatives for so now you have
these two different cultures completely
fighting over what is the definition of
like being American right I also think
there's something to be said too about
like I don't know what BART was touching
on whenever I like like I said was live
action role playing trying to get to the
anger place of like if okay guy holding
a butt like can he's he was a dude now
he's now he says he's a woman that
doesn't piss me off for whatever reason
just does I can't get mad right but the
thing that Bart was touching on where I
think it's like I send my kid to school
and then my kid comes home and they're
like in kindergarten and the teacher's
like trying to tell them about like how
they're maybe they might be trapped in
the wrong body I get why people are mad
about that yeah that makes sense to me I
don't need like a conspiracy seriously
to understand like why people are mad
about that but they're like guy holding
a Bud Light Cannon he just dresses like
however he wants to that's adult
reaction like you're you're old enough
to be like so yeah exactly well also
it's also like so the people have the
issue but then when like an organized
group that's not part of the people
it's up to them to solve the problem and
then so the result is never what the
issue that people uh want in the first
place so for example everyone want to
defund the police
and they're like okay we got to defund
the police so LASD the sheriff's
department they actually got to fund it
they got I don't know like tens of
millions of dollars and then the list
that comes out of all the Departments
that they have like boat Patrol uh like
the downtown district things that get
sacrificed which one which department
got canned and it was uh
pedophiles like that Department's gone
so now it's like pedophile Department
yeah
thank God thank God they're gone
but not like if kids get assaulted
there's no detectives assigned to that
so like all these other like five like
there's like five of them that are
pretty crazy that get canned and they're
like wait so by me defunding the police
now our kids are at risk what the [__]
so it's it's nothing feels like the
police were trying to like outsmart be
like oh you want to defend us well we'll
Define the things that you don't want to
defunds guess what all these pedophile
cops are now
it's not it's not even based off are you
happy yeah
based off of
um percentage so if burglary and
homicide is makes up 70 of the crimes
they're not going to cut that they go
they just go down percentage well I
guess there's only five sexual assault
cases per day so I guess that will you
know they still want to do a good job
and same thing with taika's cousins who
are in kindergarten they're at school
like there's the all the trans issues
and stuff and it's like cool fight for
that but then now if you leave it up to
the school district to solve the problem
now what they're doing is uh grades one
through five is Going to Be unisex
bathrooms and for us us growing up we
already know like fifth graders beat the
[__] out of first graders and that's boy
on boy now imagine the kind of like
crazy Shenanigans like a fifth grader on
a first grade girl you know it's just
gonna be like so like the way they solve
problems it's like here's the issue it's
just really bad execution yeah put it
through a another organization because
you they're the ones that I have to
produce a solution and then the result
is never what they're fighting for right
so it's like the people that are angry
and marching and they want to make a
difference they're not involved in
actually doing changing yeah so they
have a wish of like hey we want
diversity to be taught and then the
government goes sure and then they go
you guys teach diversity he goes uh you
guys teach diversity and then it gets
pushed back to the person that's
actually got to do the work but then a
parent comes up and says I disagree with
what you guys are doing and they get a
hold of focus yeah what the parent
that's fighting for the parents will go
and be like I don't want my uh
six-year-old daughter to share a
bathroom with the 12 year old boy yeah
and then because that's they're fighting
for this but then the parents kind of
get pitted against each other because
they're actually not having the same
conversation right because one's like
well I want my kid to have like trans
rights and do all this stuff and it's
like that's awesome but then because of
this Middle Ground yeah they're not
fighting the actual same issue they're
not against the initiative they're
against it I think yeah I think the
problem with like the bit of policies in
government then it's really like some
things are packaged in such a good way
right but the execution no one reads it
no one follows up on it yeah they don't
follow them that's true and it's like
look at how the DMV is ran like you want
to trust the government to actually
follow through on policies that like no
one fault that no one looks at like
that's where I'm just like yeah and if
you say no so for example right like
let's say the student loans is a big one
right A lot of people just wanted excuse
and if someone goes I don't think it's a
good idea to do it this way then people
go what the [__] is wrong with you
you're so greedy you don't
wait wait wait yeah let's look at how
they plan on making this happen I'm
saying no to the plan I'm saying no to
how they want to execute this yeah and I
think that's the issue is a lot of
people they just want quick ass
Solutions
and it always sucks like I don't trust a
lot of people to solve my problems
because they're stupid bro but that's
why it's so easy to [__] about [__] and
not to run for something and go try to
and do it yourself but at that point I
feel like we don't deserve our democracy
then because if you're not willing to
put in the work you just complain you
just go on Twitter you just don't even
do anything you don't even vote a lot of
people don't even vote but a lot of
people will argue especially nowadays by
me going on Twitter and talking about it
is helpful for the cause well but like
have you seen how how many eligible
voters there are to how many people
actually vote dude
it's so low and I mean you get jury duty
all of a sudden I'm not gonna fall for
that trick
that is that they do kind of do punish
you for participating I'm out I can't
take days off active citizens
yeah dude but at that point do you
deserve it though like I don't know yeah
you don't feel Pride about jury duty oh
no I take my job seriously but if I get
called to be a juror I take it seriously
you know what I thought was a good move
they did when they took down all those
schools like I mean I wish they did this
to all schools but when they took out
DeVry and like ITT Tech oh those were
pretty for giving uh certificates that
were worthless to people really like the
not the non-accredited schools right
yeah yeah and they gave money back to
people who spent their money at these
schools and couldn't get a job wow but
they don't do that for liberal arts
colleges that cost way the [__] more
there you go they've been around longer
yeah you're talking about my masters
from University of Phoenix doesn't mean
anything
in business bro my friend went to three
years of debris and then when he
realized that uh they're supposed they
have to be accredited transferable
credits he had to go through another
four years to get his Bachelor
because he didn't know I didn't know
that was the whole record with DeVry I
don't know if it's right I know ITT Tech
might be one of them it might be both
definitely University of Phoenix have
you seen the ones at Grand Canyon
University yeah all of them all of them
are like so anytime they're they're like
off ads on TV Ray J is talking about it
or [__] like well you know 80
rapper's son doing a commercial about it
is probably not like breakfast sucks
does Ray J just enter he's like hey it's
Ray J from the Kim Kardashian video
anyway
if the commercial pops up during daytime
television in the middle of Jerry
Springer and there's someone that goes I
used to [__] do nothing
I think Tech and I'm a technical nurse
technically I'm something now and the
b-roll is him in his backyard like
shoveling something hey I was in one of
those commercials
are you spitting on your head that was
like the first commercial I ever booked
I was in a divide commercial that played
at the movie theater so so if I went to
go watch movies back then I would see
myself in and I'm like on a computer and
I'm just like
you know people on the phones and [__]
hey
look at this [__]
the irony is I I didn't even have a
certificate from a place like that at
all I had no degree
foreign